are you catholic
i am catholic yeah but i have not been
diddled [ __ ] i got too big did you get
straight a's
i did not but i did i did well school
yeah yeah were you were you the funny
one in high school or no i was pretty
funny but i think i was i was more of a
i thought it was funny and i think
people
thought i was a bully
yeah yeah but that's the thing i was
only mean to like my friends
i wasn't like a bully to like the kids
who were like
that it would be bullying you know like
a kid without friends i'm not gonna pick
on him yeah like a guy who thought he
was cool or tried to be cool yeah i
would probably yeah yeah i
i also think that you have the size like
i think that if you and i were the same
way in high school
they would think that you were more of a
bully because of your size and to me
it's like oh he's just aggressive
right yeah i think size has a lot to do
with it i think so too because i'm
pretty bullying yeah he's a bully sure
like i i saw you pull up to the store
and would i wait like just throwing your
keys at a
car guy i figure he's talking through
them and then he walked right up to me
he was like yeah good special
started [ __ ] with people i was like
oh my god yeah i i do that i think i'm a
bully i liked it and you pulled up in a
in your car everybody else was pulling
up in cool nice cars right and what was
what was mine your was with the prius
yeah yeah yeah yeah i wasn't sure yeah
banged up previously i was like that's
that's three doors i like that yeah yeah
i did like that
all the other comics are like look at my
cool sports car i know here comes a
prius you're like [ __ ] park it
this guy's nuts
yeah like were you there when jeff ross
pulled out and
jeff ross pulled up in a batmobile
literally yeah he had some sort of
a machine that looked like a batmobile
there was like it was black
low to the ground it was like come over
a jeep like a combination between a jeep
like an like a wrangler jeep that you
would do in the desert and a batmobile
i'm not kidding you well those two are
nothing alike
let me just
picture a batmobile okay right but not
the new one from the 1960s show yeah
okay
and and then but imagine like
you know
now kind of make it look like a jeep
that's so hard to do in my brain i'm not
even
i'm not picturing a single thing yeah
but anyway pulled up on something like
that something i would never see i've
never seen anything like that before in
my life and i see guys like um like uh i
don't want to name names but um like
guys like steve byrne they come in
mercedes or andrew santino with his
[ __ ] you know bmw you know nice and i
like
just i like it too a prius i like what
you're doing banged up yeah
dirty inside yeah well can you imagine
bombing and then getting back in a
[ __ ] lamborghini
can you imagine not having ten i'd be
like bombing for ten minutes and being
like a [ __ ] and i like dressing like a
homeless person yeah and like throwing
keys at white people
[Music]
yeah yeah you know man so you should
understand the gym shorts i do
the same vibe dude it's the same you're
when i was wearing like ripped jeans and
being
cool yeah
you're a comedian
what's that old is it a book about the
two guys lenny and
mice
and men that's you guys that's us
rice and man
there he is all right my bad
okay
you need five so i'm sorry
rice and men
that's the title of this episode that's
your fault
but
right
but you're the lenny i think i'm a big i
do put off lenny vibes right many
certainly or
mad max beyond the thunderdome what's
that called
no what's it called thunder dome yeah oh
it's under dome
i know you're going what master blaster
there we go yeah
but when i said thunder dorm it threw
you off
uh it took me a second cause i was
surprised that anybody could even say
that
i mean how could you ever do that wrong
i know